Apple's hard at work on their new iPhone
16 lineup including the very first
iPhone Ultra model ever and in this
video I'm going to lay out and explain
the top 10 changes so if you chose to
skip the iPhone 15 upgrade you're in for
a treat starting with change number one
the display sizes are finally getting
bigger which is going to lead to many
improvements we have 6.9 in on the 16
Pro Max model and maybe also the ultra
and then we have 6.3 in on the regular
pro model and as for the regular iPhone
16 models they're going to be sticking
to the same 6.1 and 6.7 in sizes so
finally there's going to be a noticeable
difference between the regular and the
Pro Models now one of the biggest
concerns is that the phones are going to
be too wide and large to hold in your
hands but don't worry because this leads
us into change number two the brand new
design is going to be a little bit wider
even though the display is getting a lot
larger because the full Dimensions have
leaked for the 16 Pro and 16 Pro Max
models and going from the 15 Pro to the
16 Pro we have essentially the same
exact thickness as before the width is
going up from 70.6 mm to
71.4 five now as far as the 16 Pro Max
it's the same story getting just a
little bit wider and about 3.1 mm taller
so it'll basically be just as
comfortable to hold with that even
larger display which is great news now
change number three was a huge surprise
because as you know the iPhone 15 Pro
Models have a new action button but
guess what Apple's going to add another
brand new button exclusively for the 16
Pro Models this will apparently be a
brand new capture button which is
apparently supposed to be one of the
main selling points of the 16 Pro Models
it's going to be located beneath the
power button most likely in this area
probably in place of the current 5G
millimet wave antenna no one knows
exactly what this new button is going to
be used for but some rumors are pointing
to it being used to record spatial video
which feels more natural holding the
phone like this in landscape mode to
make sure you have the proper 3D
recording for change number four this
feature is huge and it's one that is
only possible now that apple is going to
be increasing the display size on the
iPhone 16 Pro you know that 5x optical
zoom camera on the 15 Pro Max well
because of the bigger 6.3 in display on
the smaller 16 Pro there is now going to
be more internal space which will allow
just enough room for Apple to jam-pack
this new crazy camera into the regular
16 Pro instead of being exclusive to the
pro Max personally this new 5x camera
has been my favorite feature by far on
the new 15 Pro Max and I feel bad for
everybody out there with smaller hands
that had no choice but to go with the
smaller 15 Pro size because they're
totally missing out it literally makes
it feel like you have a whole new
perspective for photos and videos with
Incredible stabilization so all of you
small-handed people out there you should
be getting pretty excited right about
now now moving on to change number five
I'm sorry that I got you excited because
this one is going to be a little bit of
a slap in your face the 16 Pro Max and
Ultra models will also be getting an
increase in size because of the larger
6.9 in display so they will therefore
also be getting more internal space and
apparently Apple's going to make the 5x
telephoto lens even better according to
digital chat station on waybo apple is
planning a 300 mm Super telephoto zoom
lens exclusively for one of those new
huge models so you're getting even
further Zoom this one right here is a
bit hard for me to believe because the
lens on the 15 Pro Max is already quite
large using a unique tetr prism lens
design so maybe that new super telephoto
might actually be using a periscope lens
instead for change number six we have
the brand new A8 line of chips which has
apparently already moved into volume
production at tsmc so this means that
the a18 pro chips are already past the
design phase and they're going to start
stocking the shelves to prep for the new
iPhone 16s and the cool thing next year
is that these chips will be built using
tsmc's second generation 3 nanometer
process node which should focus more on
efficiency and apparently the yields are
going to be much better which could mean
higher standards for performance per wat
for change number seven we're expecting
Apple to finally release their
Innovative new batteries which will
actually use a solid metal shell
completely different from their current
soft foil pouch batteries as you can see
from this leaked prototype it's a brand
new design with a larger battery with a
capacity of
3,355 milliamp hours now if you didn't
know this the reason the current casings
are soft is to allow the battery to
swell up when it gets hot or has heavy
use and there's actually free space
surrounding the entire battery to allow
that swelling to happen without
rupturing the battery and exploding like
what happened to so many Samsung phones
but with this brand new battery Tech the
batteries will no longer swell at least
as much having much better thermal
features so Apple can basically fill in
all of that extra wasted space around
the battery with a larger battery moving
on to change number eight we have
another big upgrade in terms of the
cameras one that I'm personally very
excited about because right now the
ultra wide camera is by far the worst
out of all of the ones we have on the 15
Pro Max well next year the 16 pro and
pro Max will be getting a brand new
upgraded 48 megapixel Ultra wide lens
with four times more resolution compared
to the current 12 megapixel ultrawide
for change number nine we're expecting a
massive upgrade in terms of Wi-Fi future
proofing because the 16 pro and pro Max
models are going to be getting an
upgrade to WiFi 7 which is very unique
because it's the first version of Wi-Fi
that can connect over the 2.4 gig 5 GHz
and 6 GHz bands simultaneously this this
is going to increase transfer speed
reduce latency and give you a much more
reliable connection and apparently it'll
offer Peak data transfer speeds of over
40 gbits per second and finally for
change number 10 these new iPhone 16 Pro
Models will also come with support for
5G Advanced using the new Qualcomm
Snapdragon x75 modem and this is going
to be very important because it's going
to be more power efficient saving
battery life and it's going to give you
better range and service everywhere I
have the new 15 Pro Max and I already
noticed a huge Improvement in
reliability in terms of the service
especially out where we camp every
summer which used to be a dead zone for
phone calls on my previous 14 pro Max so
I'm excited for even more improvements
in this area so there you guys go those
were the top 10 changes we are expecting
with the new iPhone 16 Pro Models if I
missed one go ahead and let me know down
in the comment section below and
subscribe above for more videos like
this one and check out one of those two
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video